welcome to the White House 2023 Stanley
Cup champion Vegas golden kns you know
it's a special place did it the first time and
I think the second time now I'm trying to take
a little bit more in and and appreciate
it for what it was yeah it's incredible
uh when else did you have the opportunity
um obviously a huge honor for all of us
to be able to come here to the White House
congrats to those incredible players led by
Captain Mark Stone it's an honor to speak on
behalf of not only my teammates but the city
of Las Vegas the entertainment uh capital of
the world say that with all due respect to
Delaware Mr President yeah I mean I was pretty
nervous president took it very well so that uh
I think that helped uh for us to be able to
come in here and uh get to experience that is
uh is pretty special the fact to come here and
you know visit and meet the President and Vice
President I think it's it's awesome but to do
it with all the organization and my teammates
I think that makes it special this team has
proved that in Vegas you can beat the eyeses